- So Will, your oldest, Violet is 15 now.
So are you nervous about
this whole driving situation?
- [Will] Well, we've
been talking about it.
Well, these like my kids, are cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Right.
They're smart. And they're
weird and they're funny.
- That's the best thing.
- They're brilliant.
And they're, they're
just, they they're my,
my biggest inspiration
and I love them so much
and we have such a great relationship.
They're really, really cool.
Violet is, right, so she's 15.
- Yeah.
- She's about to get her learner's permit.
And so she said to me,
one day, she's like,
we should talk about what
my first car should be.
- And then we should talk
about what job you're getting.
- Exactly.
(audience clapping)
And so I'm like, all
right, well, you know,
I guess we'll figure it out at some point.
And then that night
she texts me a picture.
She's like,
I think I know what my
first car's going to be.
I'm like, what's that?
And it was a picture of
Dr. Dre and Snoop Dogg
in a 64 Impala.
(cheerful laughing)
- [Kelly] Are you what even kidding?
- [Will] I was like
- [Kelly] That's amazing
- [Will] I'm not picking you
up on the side of the 4 or 5
when that thing breaks down.
- oh my god!
I'm, the thing I am nervous about
like when my kids do start to drive,
I drive a big truck
and it's such a ridiculous
thing to drive in LA,
but I'm so scared of other drivers.
And I feel like if I get in a wreck,
I'm not going down, they are. So like.
- Is that how her accent comes out
when she starts talking about trucks
(Will imitating Kelly)
- It's honestly, cause I'm tired
- Is that what it is?
- Anytime I'm tired or drinking,
I sound like a total
redneck, I'm so sorry.
- What kind of truck do you have?
- I have an F-250. It's
too big for the, it's for,
I have a Ranch Monte. I had,
it was for another place like,
but I had it here and
I, it turns out that,
I love it here.
It's totally hard to
drive here and park here.
- I got a Dodge Ram.
And like, when I'm like
driving around and truck,
you never like,
nobody you know has a truck
and you don't realize
how bad you need a truck,
until you have a friend with
a truck and they're like,
hey, will you help me
move my sofa tomorrow?
- Yeah.
Or go to, Lowe's pick
up some gardening stuff
and all you're plants
I love it. It's very handy.
I go and I leave with what I want.
I don't have to like,
have someone deliver it. Yeah.
Mama does it all on her own.
(cheering)
Um, so are you, are you dreading the day,
like your girls started dating?
- Well,
- That's a yes.
- Sort of, I have this plan.
I have got it all worked out in my head
that if one of my daughters
shows up with a musician,
I'm just going to pull that person aside
and I'm going to say,
look,
I will get you a record contract.
- If you stop picking out for.
- If you leave her alone.
I will do this.